next Oh give it to your mom wait for you
to get it on your own and still deliver
to you I guess you're gonna do a
superhero laughing wait for it
whoa superhero landing yeah that's
really hard on your knees totally
impractical I'll do it you're a lovely
lady but I'm saving myself for Francis
that's why I brought him I'd prefer him
not to hit a woman
so please
I mean that's why I brought her oh no
finish your tweet it's not your fence
but just give us a second
there you go hashtag it go get her
oh I so pity the dude who pressures her
into prom sex he wants you to come to
him who is it that's the turd emoji I
thought it was chocolate yogurt for so
long
oh there's the money shot baby damn I'm
totally on top of this
I never say this but don't swallow bad
guy he's got my girl I'm gonna get her
back
I go with you but I don't wanna
that's all the pieces in the house no no
no no come on hand it over up up down
down down down I was like Robin to my
Batman and except she's blind you
haven't had anything in here and seed be
surprised
hey youtubers it's Charlie new Deadpool
footage we got to talk about but first
let me know when you saw the title of
this you are like wait is this the two
girls one cup thing or is this one punch
man very very big difference between
those two things you can't see it
because the camera is cutting it off but
I'm actually wearing my one punch ugly
Christmas sweater which totally did not
just arrive in time for Christmas I was
pissed I feel like it's hard to troll
people like it's hard to troll your
friends nowadays with clips like two
girls one cup but anybody that remembers
that will never forget it it is burned
into your brain let me know in the
comments though did you ever try to use
the two girls one cup video to troll one
of your friends or your family members
did they turn around and throw up on you
or punch you in the face if you answer
yes give yourself a giant high-five
there's totally Internet trolling that
came before that that's way way worse
but I just I totally loved that they did
stuff like this you look at the title
and then one either throw up from PTSD
or you just start screaming at your desk
I don't know what else wait wait what
what look what
[Music]
no but just to go over the new stuff
blind out you guys may be familiar with
her from the comics if you're not she's
this huge character in the Deadpool
mythos and it's later found out that she
is the original Black Widow so you get
the idea is really good with weapons but
she's this crinkly old lady to get this
Yoda type revealed that she's secretly a
badass just because she's old doesn't
mean she still can't kick ass in the
context of the story she's more of a
mother figure a confidante to always
some reason I don't know if the movies
gonna change anything about her
backstory but the bit about her being
the original Black Widow isn't really
canon to the comics anymore but she did
date Captain America back in the 1940s
so yeah she's pretty old hobbies include
needlepoint thimble collecting planning
escape routes watching Matlock and she
loves The Daily Show if you haven't seen
Fox has been doing some preview
screenings of the movie so be sure to
double-check if there are any in your
area I think it's mostly happening in
Los Angeles and New York there is
another one happening in New York really
soon and if you do have the chance to
see it early just be careful when you're
posting spoilers on my Deadpool video
because a lot of people won't be able to
see it till it actually hits theaters I
haven't had a chance to see it but I'm
gonna wait to post my video till it hits
theaters officially so no worries there
I'll do a non-spoilery one I'll do a
spoiler e1 with Easter eggs there'll be
a post-credits scene there is a
post-credits scene so make sure you stay
through the credits my guess is just
being the Deadpool's in the x-men
universe is gonna be x-men related I am
working on a new Batman V Superman video
why you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for all my other Deadpool
videos and you can click here for the
Game of Thrones teaser that I just
posted thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you